We're going to use our knowledge of perfect square trinomials to help us
complete the square. To complete the square means to change a polynomial into a
perfect square trinomial. Let's consider this polynomial, x squared plus 4x.
Now, let's use some tiles to help us visualize this polynomial. Here, we have a
square that measures x by x. So its area is x squared, and here, we have 4 x's.
We know that this side is also x and this side is just one unit long. So, 1
times x equals x, the area of this tile. So, if we wanted to have a perfect
square, how many one tiles do you think we needed to add here to do that? In
other words, what number should we add to our polynomial in order to get a
perfect square?